when you are in the mind of the
character you're there you're just
completely believing what he says in
that way you let the story go you let it
go you you're here with your beliefs
you're here with your vision you let the
story go and just tell itself hey hey
and welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special with special guest Andrew
Clavin who you may know from such things
as me pitching membership at the Daily
wire we'll get to all of that but first
let's talk about your quality of sleep
so there is nobody on the planet like
you so why would you buy a generic
mattress built for someone else helix
sleep has built a sleep quiz it takes
two minutes to complete they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether your side sleeper or
your hot sleeper you like a plush or
firm bed with helix there's no more
guessing and no more confusion just go
to helix sleep calm slash bed and guest
you take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they will match you to a mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life four couples
helix can even split that mattress down
the middle they can provide individual
support needs and fuel preferences for
each side they've a 10-year warranty you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free so you really have nothing to
lose right now helix is offering up to
125 bucks off all mattress orders again
that's up to 125 bucks off at helix
sleep comm slash been guest because I
have a guest that's helix sleep calm
slash been guest for 125 bucks off your
mattress order my wife and I have a
helix sleep mattress we'd sleep on it
every evening and it is fantastic it's
so good that when my sister got married
we got her a helix sleep mattress as
well it's a luxury mattress at a nominal
cherry price helix sleep calm
been guests and you get 125 bucks off
your mattress order helix sleep calm
slash been guest drew I have to start by
asking you what the heck is another it's
it's a story about a this kind of little
schlub a nebbish
in hollywood who's come out to be a big
film maker a little bit of success and
they're all melted away and now he's
turning 30 he's not happy he knows he
can see he's going down that road where
he's never gonna quite make it never
gonna pull away Hollywood is filled with
people like this and everything is just
kind of going wrong in his life and one
day he opens the door walks through the
door and he finds himself in a locked
room in a medieval castle a dead body on
the floor and a bloody dagger in his
hand
and the cards kick down the door grab
him drag him throw him into a dungeon
and tell him he's going to trial for his
life and he can't he can't believe
thinks he must have a brain to him and
the weird thing that keeps happening to
him is every now and again he'll go
through another door he'll be back in
Hollywood like a minute later a second
later than no time passes and in
Hollywood he finds that people are
hunting him all of a sudden and he has
no idea why and so these two mysteries
were unfolding on - in two completely
different worlds and yet somehow this
one character there's nobody
this guy that nobody's ever heard of
nobody ever would hurt Europe is somehow
holding these two worlds together and
holding these two mysteries together and
has to find the answer before he gets
himself killed so how do you come up
with the ideas for these fictional
worlds especially this one normally been
doing hard-boiled fiction and this one
is is hard well fiction slash fantasy
which is a really interesting mashup
this one you know I only recently
realized how this book came to be
because it's happened so organically and
looking back on it it's actually a big
experience I mean I was a crime writer
that's all I ever did was crime and
suspense and and I would turn out a book
every year to two years but I was always
working on a novel and then I got to the
point where I wrote my memoir the great
good thing and without even noticing it
I stopped I stopped writing I didn't
even notice it was happening because I
was continually writing short stories I
wrote a couple of books that I didn't
publish that I threw away and only
looking back on it that I realized that
writing that memoir I had finally put
down all the stuff that I had been
thinking about and had worked out all
the problems that made my fiction tick
because you're always as a novelist
you're actually writing beyond what you
know because you're actually working
ideas out in stories in the story form
so you're not you're not saying like oh
here's a story that's gonna be about X Y
& Z you're saying here's a story about a
guy doing this and only later do you
realize oh it was kind of about X Y & Z
that I've been thinking about on this
side so when I wrote the great good
thing I actually caught up with myself
and I realized now I've answered all
these questions that powered all the
stories of my youth I didn't have
anything else really to say and when I
was becoming a Christian one of the
repeated thoughts that was going through
my mind was oh Lord
don't let me become a Christian novelist
because you know what they're like that
horrible horrible stuff
like like oh I lost my bunny but Jesus
brought it back so I didn't want to do
that and I wrote two novels that were
essentially Christian novels that I
didn't like and one of them I tried and
tried to rewrite and I tried again and
again I was sitting at a table in my
living room with a manuscript and I
caught on the coffee table and this
notepad trying to fix it and I realize
I'm gonna have to throw this book out
I've been working on this but for years
we have to throw this book away and
almost simultaneously another kingdom
went bang just dropped into my mind and
it came in hole and my process is
usually I get a little idea I put it
away for six months it comes back it's
bigger it gets bigger over a course
every year it finally flushes out it was
all there and when I sat down to write
it I thought well I have an entire story
is there and so I really didn't realize
what had happened but I wasn't gonna
look a gift horse in the mouth and I
just started writing the story out and
it came very organically the world
created itself like I didn't even sit
there normally I'm very very picky and
do a lot of outlines and here's where
this city is gonna be here's where that
cities gonna be all of it just worked
itself out and in an instant you know
and I realized that my subconscious had
solved this problem it had solved the
problem of how to write a book once you
have gotten to a point where you
actually have a belief system because
belief systems kill fiction you know the
world fiction is like the world you can
put any number of beliefs onto the world
that that work you know and fiction
should be the same way it should show
life so honestly that Aniela scan look
at a work by a fiction by a Christian
and say like yeah I understand that and
it kind of he thinks he's Christian but
the story is not all our stuff and I
needed to get beyond that and I think
the thing about another Kingdom is it
because it works on two levels because
it's a very realistic thriller story
very gritty we kind of knew our thriller
story and also this very almost
old-fashioned medieval you know a
fantasy story it's these two levels in
in my own mind talking to one another
the fact that I am a realist I believe
that the world is a material world I
believe that everything can be explained
through materialism that every piece of
our bodies can you know I could trade
every thought in my mind the same time I
believe that there is a new mineral
plane that where the spirit lives and
that that our flesh tells a story about
our flesh is telling a story about the
spirit you know and so it actually
allowed me to write that without ever
writing a Christian book so how did you
avoid becoming didactic because I
noticed that you know I've written a
bunch of non-fiction books I wrote one
fiction book it was much harder for me
than writing nonfiction
yeah because nonfiction is me expressing
my views and exploring philosophy but
fiction it's like well am I supposed to
be veiling the idea or am I supposed to
be telling a story and if I tell a story
I'm why am I getting bored with my own
story how did how did you bridge that
gap between now you have a set worldview
but still being interested in the
fiction that you're writing yourself
because it seems to me that's sometimes
the number one barrier of being a writer
is being interested in what you're doing
on a daily basis that's it you have to
put it aside you actually have to put it
aside you have to trust yourself to see
the world as you see it but you have to
love your characters you have to let
your characters live the life they live
you know you can't you can't write a
Macbeth who doesn't actually believe in
what he's doing you can't write a
villain who doesn't actually think like
he's right some level you know who isn't
actually know you're an idiot for being
the good guy I've got I figured it out
you know you have to live with that so
there's an element of almost method
acting in it where when you are in the
mind of the character you're there
you're just completely believing what he
says in that way you let the story go
you let it go you you're here with your
beliefs you're here with your vision you
let the story go and just tell itself
what's your process for writing I mean
you said that you do a lot of outlining
does that turn it workman like or did
you actually sit down and you just kind
of let it flow it's the only part of my
work I hate the outlining I mean it's
boring it's you know it's close work and
you just have to sit there and do it
there's no excitement no character in it
even though I write a lot of biographies
for characters and things like that
however if you do that work I've now
learned when you sit down to write
you're free you know you know that in
this scene the guy is gonna you know run
down that hallway and he's gonna find
such-and-such and you don't have to sit
there stare at that blank screen which
is of course the nightmare of every
writer writer has so I do do that I do a
lot of prep work and it's really helpful
and what I now try to do is I try and do
it a little bit of
day because it's just so excruciating
it's just the one part of the job I love
my work and I really do love it and I
but it's the one part of the job I just
think I got to do this I got to work it
out so what's your schedule on a
day-to-day basis because you come in
here you don't get a lot of sleep you
coming here you do your podcast and then
you're writing hours and hours a day how
do you first of all how do you clear the
time and second of all so take me from
you wake up to you go to bed base what's
your schedule during your normal day
well I wake up I wake up at the you know
5:15 five to the thirty yet aweful I
know and the first thing I do like I say
hello to my wife and I grab my iPad I
start reading the news you know what's
going on guess catching up on everything
and I do that pretty solidly until I
start to prep the show which you know
I'm prepping the show by around 6:30
plus you know and and then I do that I
stop I stop for maybe about 45 minutes
to do kind of faith stuff I read the
Gospels and in Greek which I'm so proud
of I taught my school creaking and and
then I read some Old Testament some
faith you know other other kinds of
stuff and then come in and do the show
and then I go home right you know and I
somebody asked me how do I got along
with no sleep and I told them I take
naps while other people are expressing
their opinions but but yeah no I I just
keep going and then I'm done by about
7:00 so I'm working a long day but I'm
sure you do too I'm working like a 1214
hours yeah I mean what time you go to
sleep normally I go to sleep late
because I don't sleep a lot so I go to
how do you deal with how you work oh
yeah yeah I just on coffee I mean those
do you use any of it no I've never taken
anything like that I take I don't drink
that much coffee I drink like two two
and a half cups of coffee there you know
and like I just don't sleep I don't like
going to bed I don't like being asleep
you know I feel like I'm missing
something you know one of those internet
phrases fear of missing out so I kind of
like I felt the same way and then I have
young kids you know I can avoid it
I couldn't wait for them to go there
that for sure but then it's like now I
just need to fall over because maybe I
ragged and and I do take cat naps that
was the one thing when I was a little
kid Thomas Edison was my hero
and he always he took cat naps I think I
modeled that on him so that really helps
okay so let's go through some of your
faith journey because you know the
obviously that's shaping how you're
seeing the world in terms of your
fiction writing and you have a pretty
interesting faith journey obviously you
and I ended up in very separate places
but but you you started off you're born
into a Jewish family I've said to you
before we've had this conversation but
you you were born into extraordinarily
secular Jewish family right so and now
obviously you're religious Christians
how do you get from point A to point B
well the weird thing about my family was
there was secular but it was also
committed to my father at least was
committed to the traditions so we went
to Hebrew school we were bar Mitzvahed
we learned this stuff but it did occur
to me that I've always had this I don't
call it an obsession that's a little too
much but I've always had this idea that
things should make sense if things don't
make sense you should change your mind
and and part of that was because of a
kind of dysfunctional atmosphere in my
house where we were taught a lot of
philosophical ideas that were just
untrue and and it's very damaging you
know because you don't want to tear away
from your family but at the same time
you want to find the truth and so I
became kind of obsessed with finding the
truth so you there praying and you're
there learning Hebrew which is not my
language and you're there wearing the
you know the Hat and the thing you think
well if there's no God and my mother was
a stone atheist and my father was just
kind of like you know he didn't want to
even want to get in trouble with God but
like he wasn't exactly believin to me
that and and after when I stress I think
well this is ridiculous this is
ridiculous so after my bar mitzvah I
mean that was kind of the turning point
I was bar Mitzvahed I got thousands of
dollars worth of gifts that I put in
this box and one day I got up and threw
the box away because with everything in
it and I just thought like you know this
the old lady at the end of Titanic yeah
exactly
it'll gotten games you know this is not
what I I wanted I didn't really I expect
it to live my life as a sort of
intellectual agnostic you know like the
way I mean I think this kind of it was
the default position of thinking men and
my day you know and it's kind of still
is still now is that yeah right and I
and I think that was going to be it that
was
really my position which is very
flattering to the intellectual mind
because you can analyze everything into
dust if you just no matter how small the
point is you can break it up into even
smaller pieces because you don't have
that bottom line there has to be meaning
there has to be more ality that has me
the problem was when I was 19 I read
crime and punishment
and it convinced me that the moral world
existed it convinced me that cotton was
right there was the starry sky above and
the moral law within and that was that
was undeniably true and because of that
I kept circling around where does this
morality and meaning come from and I'm
not I wasn't satisfied with things I
hear from guys like our pal Jordan
Peterson the the Italian philosopher
marchello Peres you know I say just live
as if there were God I think to live as
if there were a god is essentially to
want the conclusions of a syllogism
whose premises you don't accept right
and it just makes no sense and so again
everything had to make sense to me
and and ultimately I mean I had when I
was a kid I've lived like these two
lives I had terrible emotional problems
because I had a terrible relationship
with my father my my household was
dysfunctional in this very invisible way
there's not a lot of violence there's
not a lot of hatred it was just this
kind of invisible dysfunction and so I
cracked up you know there came a point
when I was like 28 years old I just
stopped working basically I just went
boom you know something's wrong and at
that point which was would have been the
smart point to seize hold of God like a
piece of driftwood floating by in the
ocean I thought like well that then I'll
never believe because it'll always be
this thing I did because I was weak
because I was down on my luck because I
was broken it'll always be this crutch
that I see used to hold up it's just
really how stubborn I was about things
making sense you know and and so instead
by the grace of God I found a shrink who
cured me and I always laugh about this
I'm the only person I've ever known it
was cured by psyche but but he did you
know it within the course of like 2 3
years of talking to this guy I was a
completely different human being and it
was only then when I felt sane when I
felt certain that my impressions were
correct when I felt certain that I was
not
in a delusional life that it seemed
obvious to me that there was God because
of my moral stance in the stance that if
everybody on earth there was a time
there was a time when everybody on earth
believed this slavery was right even the
slaves they would have said yeah I don't
want to be the slave but this is the way
things are at that time slavery was
wrong and once you say that you're
screwed with God wise I mean you cannot
you cannot get away from the idea that
somewhere there is this moral base this
base of meaning and this is the thing
that's become fascinating to me now
because they're guys like you and me who
actually believe but we're kind of
anomalies in the world of the thinking
man I think there's a there is right now
the world of the thinking man's divided
by into two on one side you have people
like Jordan Peterson Marcela Parra
Douglas Perry who wrote that book the
strange death of Europe and we're back
the novel is weird like not will but who
are basically saying the West can't
survive without the judeo-christian
thesis we should all ascribe to the
judeo-christian thesis I myself do not
believe right they're all saying the
same thing I myself cannot believe on
the other side you have these guys like
you've all her re and who wrote say
pians and Steven Pinker who say no no no
my friend you know we are going up and
up and up this has been an absolute no
get to her Ari I think the Harari is at
least more intellectually honest and
then Pinker I mean I think the Pinker
does this whole routine where the
Enlightenment will save us and
everything is going to continuously get
better and you carve away the
foundations of Western civilization
nothing will crumble and Harare is
basically like well maybe civilization
sucked in the first place right just go
back to living in the fields and we were
happy when we were eating grass and all
this kind of stuff and at least at least
he's honest that way and he has this
kind of Vulcan idea that we're all
living in a delusion like he's the
problem with him is he says the most
unique his phrase I would never say the
most unique but he does he says the most
unique thing about sapiens is the
fictions we create so we have a fiction
that there's a god we have a fiction
that we have human rights we have a
fiction of money money hasn't values us
but that's not how fiction works
I mean fiction fiction described
something it does not create things I
can I can create a delusional world
through fiction but good fiction
it describes reality so money is a good
example money describes the value of
something to a human being when he has a
lot of it or when he doesn't have a lot
of it that's what it describes you know
it's actually it actually does have a
value that we're accepting the the paper
doesn't but the idea does and because
Harare is a Vulcan who doesn't accept
that there is a human life that matters
he thinks it's all being created by the
fictions but the fictions are being
created by that internal life well it's
talk some more about this but first
let's talk about your nuts we're talking
my money Robin Hood is an investing app
that lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and crypto is all
commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just for wealthy
folks it's a non intimidating way for
stock market newcomers to invest for the
first time with actual confidence it was
simple an intuitive design data
presented is an eating the easy to do
just way go check it out right now
especially because they also have a
charging structure that makes sense in
other words no Commission fees you trade
stocks and keep all of your profits easy
to understand charts market data you can
place a trade in just four taps on your
smartphone what are you waiting for
Robin Hood even has a web platform that
lets you view stock collections and
analyst ratings buy a whole that and
sell for every stock you can learn how
to invest as you build that portfolio
discover new stocks track favorite
companies with a personalized news feed
it is a one-stop shop for investing
Robin Hood right now is giving my
listeners a free stock like Apple Ford
or Sprint's to help you build your
portfolio sign up at Ben Shapiro Robin
Hood calm that's Ben Shapiro
Robin Hood calm okay so let's go back to
where we were here yeah I I agree I mean
I think that there is this this divide
and neither of the two sides of the
divide are destined to preserve the
civilization right you can't though I
agree there's the one side with folks
like Jordan and I love Jordan but
Jordan's Jordans essential argument
which is that all of the outgrowth of
Western civilization are fantastic all
of the outgrowths of judeo-christian
value systems are great these myths
represent fundamental values but then he
boils that down to repeated game play
through Piaget it's like well I asked
him this when he was sitting in your
seat yeah I said well then why is it
that all of these values only emerged in
one culture over time like this is that
this is the unanswerable question for
folks who think there's nothing special
about judeo-christian civilization if
you all think that it's evolutionary
biology if you all think like EO Wilson
that anything can be driven by
genetics and environment we're not all
that different are you gonna tell me
that because the climate was slightly
different in China than it was in Europe
that's what generated these massive
differences in human rights and belief
in the individual that occurred over
thousands of years is that that's really
what happened here so you've got that
that one system where folks basically
argue that there is a truth but not
really a truth like Jordans at least
honest enough to acknowledge when he
says that something is true he doesn't
mean it's objectively true right
he sort of means it's useful and then
you have the folks who say well then
there's the objectively true sam harris
evo Harari
there's no such thing as free will
there's no such thing as civilization
these are all fictional creations but
then they rely on those principles in
order to create an impetus for change
right because they'll say we need to
work toward something better or we need
like there are so many different
falsities in that one statement we need
to work toward something better that's
right like how do you work if in a world
with no free well what is better in this
world and what are is this need coming
from because even when you say that we
need to do something and you say well
that's based on human flourishing we
have a lot of different definitions of
human flourishing this idea that human
flourishing is just basic Marxist
materialism is quite insane I mean if
that were the case we would not have a
crisis of conscience in the West right
now where the richest we've ever been in
human history that's why and why should
I care whether humans flourish or not as
long as I get mine and right that is the
you know all of these guys who failed to
deal with the - what to me is this
immense elephant in the room which is
the elephant of narrative and you know I
frequently talk about the fact that
George Washington was a massive hero of
Liberty a man who essentially gave the
the airing nothing of Liberty a local
habitation in the name but by turning
down the kingship by doing what he did
but he didn't understand why his slaves
didn't work hard he didn't understand
why his slaves when he treated them well
would escape and he think well how is
that possible that this hero of Liberty
didn't understand the desire for liberty
that's a narrative that is what the the
kind of atmosphere of value that
surrounds us all that we don't even know
is there the left makes the mistake that
they think that narrative is fact they
think if you control the narrative the
facts will change
the right makes the mistake of thinking
that facts will always triumph over
narrative and that's just not true
either and the thing is we are living
and this is the the one thing I agree
with Pinker on although he wouldn't
think I was agreeing with him we are
living in what I call the Enlightenment
narrative Rome fell plunged into
darkness the church held us in this
superstition then hora their classic
works were rediscovered we were reborn
in the Renaissance we moved into the
Enlightenment you know people got rid of
Protestantism for deism deism fell apart
that science marched on now we're free
into you know to march into the heavenly
world through atheism listen I think
there's a lot of truth in that you know
it's true that when Ben Franklin
invented the lightning rod the churches
were still ringing the bells to chase
the demons away when lightning came
which we didn't work out well for the
bell ringers not a good place to be
yeah and it's true you know the church
is always saying well the story of
Galileo is much more complex it is but
it's exemplary of misplaced religious
authority religious authority should not
have the capability to say to a
scientist no the earth goes here instead
of there
that's the scientists job so that it's
true to that extent but the other side
of this is exactly what you're talking
about
it only happened in the West the
invention of science as we know it
happened because Christian members of
the church almost all of them
Christian deeply believe in Christian
man started to think well if the world
makes sense if God made us in His image
it must be through the through the
connection of reason let us use our
reason to understand the starry heavens
that God has put in front of us you know
it's like all all of this was built into
judeo-christian thought and and so you
know when Jesus said not only will you
do the works I've done you'll do even
greater works that may well have been
what he was talking about he may have
said think like this and the world will
open itself up to you and that's I think
the the narrative that we have got to
start to tell because this narrative has
got people I think like Jordan and Perry
and Marcelo para it's got them in its
grip and they can't get out of it in the
same way that Washington couldn't see
his slaves should be free they can't say
that God has given them everything it
seems like a soft form of the argument
that you hear most people make about why
they became it religious
the first place which is not that they
stopped believing in God but because
people suck so what they'll say is that
they'll say I stopped being religious
because I saw all these religious people
who are acting like jerks as well that's
not a referendum on god that's a
referendum on human being sucking this
is this is this goes back to another
Kingdom which is the thing that I
realized was I was looking back on it
now all I was doing it looking back on
this the reason we can't write a
Christian good Christian novel is that
people believe up not down you don't
explain to them Aquinas said this and
then they say ah now I see there must be
a god and therefore I will believe they
get to God they climb to God on the
ladder of being you know and that ladder
the first step of that ladder is that
life is good not your life not my life
but life itself when when Hamlet says to
be or not to be that is the question
that is the question once you decide in
favor of being then you start to say
that life is good and just like you were
saying before that their sentence makes
no sense we must work to get better the
sentence that life is good and makes no
sense unless you have at the top of that
ladder an actual referendum on meaning
and morality which turns out to be God
yeah I mean this is what it says in
Deuteronomy right choose lights that you
and your children may live this is right
there I mean the most important
sentences in human history for all the
crap the Bible has taken all of the most
important sentences in human history are
in that book right I mean the to me the
most the single most important sentence
ever written whether you believe it was
by God or by man doesn't really matter
for this point when you say that man is
made in God's image that is the single
most important sentence ever written
because all of human Liberty all of
human rights all of individual equality
all of that is based in that in that
root belief and that is something you
have to take on faith and this is where
the Enlightenment thinkers you know make
me crazy because I think that first of
all I think there's a false a
falsification of enlightenment history
when you suggest that all of the
Enlightenment thinkers were basically
militant atheists who decided to reject
Church that's just not the case Locke
spent half his life doing a Christian
apologetics and Wright Newton Newton -
and and even even Voltaire was smart
enough to recognize and his old own kind
of Peter Sonia in fashion that well I'm
not somebody who deeply believes I
certainly hope that my servants are all
right because doesn't want them stealing
the silverware
so it's the the difference between the
England the English enlightenment
discussion and the American
Enlightenment and the Enlightenment of
France is that the Enlightenment of
France base
we said right there is no God there is
no moral system and using the pure light
of human reason we can recreate any
moral system that we choose and folks
who are kind of new Enlightenment
thinkers pick that up and they say that
that's the stuff that created the modern
world and I just don't understand that
what created the modern world is this
common law believing solidly religious
community that had it as its fringe
Enlightenment thinkers all of whom
recognized that without a moral and
religious people all of this would
collapse into dust nearly immediately
this is the thing the try you know I
don't understand this either like the
pinker does this Jonah Goldberg who I
love I think he's a wonderful writer but
he does it in his book as they pick on
the Romantics and they say oh the
romantics they want to go back to
feeling which is I mean these were some
of the most brilliant men who ever lived
they weren't sitting around going oh my
fields you know they were actually
thinking about something what they were
thinking about was that without religion
matter and meaning had become
irreparably separated how do we bring
them back together knowing what we know
now you know and they the thing is they
saw the French Revolution Wordsworth was
there he went to France he saw the
French Revolution he saw the priests
bayonetted in the streets he came back
and he said you know what this reason
thing is problematic you know and they
crucified him they did just what they do
to conservatives today you know they
were writing poems about what a jerk he
was you know Robert Browning wrote this
thing about how he sold out by becoming
the poet laureate a position he turned
down like three times before he finally
took it Hey but he saw this thing go
wrong and so he said like like the
second level of British romantics guys
like Coleridge and I had feats and
Shelley and but they saw it something
had happened you know that this wasn't
working
guys like Pinker it's like it never
happened there was no terror it's
amazing he writes a 400 page book called
enlightenment now and there's I check
the index the first thing I did when I
got the book there's not a single
mention of the French Revolution a book
titled enlightenment now and I don't
know how that is even possible how is
that even humanly possible and I listen
I like a lot of things even before me -
I took a class with him when I was at
Harvard it was a weird class him Alan
Dershowitz teaching it but it was it but
that necessity on the one hand to paint
the Enlightenment as all good no bad so
there's the Enlightenment then there's
the counter enlightenment everything bad
we can attribute to the counter right
right and then there is the feeling that
the enlightenment is only bad because
the people I don't like are part of it
all right so the enlightenment is either
Rousseau so everybody gets the
Enlightenment wrong in my view basically
I think there's there's the one side the
Patricks I mean wild liberalism failed
which is taking the leftist premise or
not the leftist premise but this kind of
neo Enlightenment premise that the
Enlightenment was atheistic and
individualistic without any regard for
virtue and that's what's destroyed the
West and then you have people like
Pinker taking the other side saying well
that's what built the West is that
individualistic enlightenment no virtue
we're all just kind of man to billion
B's and we bounce off of each other all
the time and the reality is that what
built America was the conjunction of
virtue and rights it was a deep belief
on the part of every single founder
including founders who considered
themselves deists that if you did not
believe in at least a Greek geological
version of virtue if you do not believe
in natural law then none of this
mattered in the first place that's the
practice but we'll drink me I don't know
how you read any of these Enlightenment
thinkers where the foundations for
either British enlightenment or American
Enlightenment and the way they talk
about natural law and not see that that
has some sort of connection to you know
the 2000 year Christian history of
natural Lanka yeah there's it's also you
can't sloth off 2,000 years of Christian
history there's that you cannot just
rewrite your mind into this completely
blank slate it just doesn't work this
one I said it Sam Harris and address it
drove me a wall I mean it's it's just
hehehe I really like Sam his person but
he's never answered at least to my
satisfaction the simple question is why
he and I hold the same values like we
have 95% of the same values and I said
to him you know where these values
coming from Sam he said well you know I
studied Buddhism and I studied
philosophy in when I was at I think it's
at Berkeley or Stanford and I and you
know I studied all this stuff and said
right but I didn't study into that stuff
and we have the same basic morality
could it be that maybe it's because we
live in a judeo-christian culture
created by 3,000 years of common history
you know maybe be that one of the most
telling narratives of the of the
American Founding is the moment when
Benjamin Frank
Franklin rewrote a portion of the
Declaration and Jefferson had said that
our rights were sacred and Franklin said
our rights are self-evident because
Franklin was a scientist right if you
think about that what Franklin was
saying is we now know
enough to do satellites we now know
enough that we you know you don't always
know that much but we now have enough
information but what was that
information it was surely the
information that had been formed over
thousands of years of Christian shaping
molding of the Western mind it was the
idea that you were an individual the
idea that you were sacred that you
mattered that you were made in God's
image all those things didn't just
disappear from Franklin's mind because
he was a bit of a vague vague about
religion because he wasn't a very good
theological thinker when he said that it
was self it was self-evident but it
wasn't self-evident 2,000 years before
that right and I think that that was a
great advance in our knowledge in the
same way I was talking about how I wrote
my memoir I where I could now contain
what I said I think the Constitution and
the Declaration are just that I think
that is European history saying here's
what we know so far here is what we know
about governance it didn't just come out
it didn't just pop out of like Cicero's
mind it actually was shaped it informed
the Greeks and the Romans shaped and
formed by these two thousand years of
Christian Judeo Christian thought which
made it what it is and you don't just
get rid of that it obviously is the
cauldron in which we were all shaped now
I'm talk a little bit about you know the
the gas running out of the tank so to
speak in Western civilization but first
let's talk about your imminent demise so
life insurance is really important
one-third of people don't have it that's
because it's actually kind of hard to
buy you have to work out what you need
and then you do the research to find the
best quote and then you hope that you
don't get swindled along the way it's
not a good way to shop for anything let
alone life insurance so policy genius
has made the whole process a lot easier
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies and they
find the best policy for you it takes
two minutes to get a quote that's simple
and if you don't know the first thing
about insurance well they've got all the
tools to get you up to speed you can
learn the difference between term and
whole life insurance you can calculate
how much coverage you need you can be
sure that you're making the right
decision
in fact over four million people have
used policy genius to shop for insurance
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they also do disability
insurance and home insurance and auto
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so whether you know a lot about
life insurance or you know nothing at
all you can start your search of policy
genius Scott again two minutes to
compare quotes and make an informed
decision for you and your loved ones
when your plots don't leave your loved
ones shoving you into a paupers tomb
instead go to policy genius and make
sure that you've got the life insurance
you actually need and when you listen
this conversation between me and drew
and what you will see is that you have
the life insurance that you need for the
afterlife but for this life you're going
to need some money if you fly so go
check it out right now policy genius the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance okay so I get the feeling
right now there is a crisis of
conscience happening in the West a
crisis of meaning I see it particularly
among young people I think that it's
manifested itself in this new attempt to
buy young people particularly claw their
way back to some sort of philosophy that
provides meaning for them and you're
seeing people Kallang in every direction
so you're seeing a lot of folks who are
returning to Jordan's worldview that
there is something worth fighting for
here and while he and I and you and he
may disagree on how far that goes we
agreed probably on eight of the 10 steps
that you need to get to the final two
being you need to believe in God you
need to believe a moral system springing
from God but he doesn't he may disagree
with that although he's never been like
incredibly clear on that and then there
are people who are clawing their way
back to meaning through partisan
tribalism which is I'm just gonna find
the group that believes most like me and
I will find meaning in my life by
clubbing the crap out of people whoever
I don't like them all of this speaks to
me of a problem that actually did exist
in the Enlightenment and that was that
the Enlightenment didn't necessarily
want to discard God or judeo-christian
morality but it ended up doing so that's
right and so we've been living off of
these fundamental premises of religion
for 200 years while simultaneously
undermining religion itself so we've
been saying reason means everything well
where does reason come from and why why
isn't it just random synapses firing in
your brain that are evolutionarily
beneficial we believe in a predictable
universe that we can explore through
through science what makes you believe
in a predictable universe where are you
getting that from
why isn't it just us theorizing and then
some theories work in some theories
don't and where where do you get the
idea that there is a good and there is a
bad where do you get the idea of any
sort of directional human living where
were you getting all of these ideas and
folks who don't believe in a
judeo-christian foundation for our
civilization I don't know how they
answer that question and I think most
people don't know the answers and so
what we've fallen into is sort of either
a passionate rejection of the question
itself as in the Bible stupid all of
this is stupid I don't really care so
your question stupids I'm just gonna do
what I want to do and I'll ignore the
question or
engaging with the question which
inevitably takes you to nihilism if you
actually can't find meaning anywhere it
seems to me that sort of the split I
think that one of the problems too is
that nobody is engaged with the question
of whether and this is what I believe I
believe atheism is obsolete
I believe it actually made sense after
Newton you know one of the reasons the
romantics he hated Newton is they feared
that by the logic of his science he had
taken the fantastic and the beautiful
and spiritual out of life and the
Romantic poets Wordsworth and Keith's
would toast long life to Newton and
confusion to mathematics I didn't you
know they thought that he was taking the
enchantment out of why I think baseball
fans in hate bill game exactly know it
exactly like that but the thing is that
that made sense at that point to think
like ah well here he's gotten logic for
this so eventually we're gonna have this
clockwork universe where everything is
gonna hold together but in fact along
the way if you've paid attention that
clockwork universe has started to get a
little weird you know that we have
effects at the quantum level that don't
make any sense at all in terms of
clockwork interplays between
consciousness and reality that really do
to me suggest an idea of consciousness
at the very beginning of creation we
have this this other idea that suddenly
when I say that life is good and that
implies a lot of philosophical problems
one of them is how can there possibly be
life the odds against there being life
are fantastic and so guys like Pinker
have invented this completely bogus idea
that there are infinite universes and
this just happens to be the universe
right unfalsifiable
which means I know it is not science
well they used to say the religious
people had God of the gaps right a god
yeah but this is religion a science of
the gaps yeah and and there's that and
then there's this other thing which
essentially is faith which is the idea
that we're living in kind of as a
computer simulation which just means
that God is a little nerd sitting there
so he's a few pad Manzanilla and so it's
actually that our narrative has not
caught up with our knowledge I think our
knowledge has gone beyond the fact where
we have to deduce an atheistic clockwork
world and it's dangerous I think that
you and I both believe this it is a
dangerous place to live without meaning
one of the things that truly bothered me
about Pinker's work and I don't again
to pick on it you know his stuff said
he's he's the stand-in version right
that's all and I think he's a man of
goodwill writing what he thinks and all
this but he he denigrates intellectuals
who say oh we've got a problem coming up
he says this is kind of natural for
intellectuals to do to see a crisis
everywhere he says we've gotten to where
we have to talk about a serious crisis
just to make sure people understand what
we're saying and every time I would read
that I would think about the Queen
Victoria's Diamond Jubilee which was the
last time that civilization was at this
pinnacle I mean just a amazing pinnacle
that it had never been at before in
England but in your throughout and they
asked the poet Kipling to write about it
and he wrote that famous poem
recessional where he said you know Lord
God of hosts he'd be with us yet lest we
forget lest we forget if we leave God
behind and he was no great believer
coupling but he said if we leave God
behind well collapse now that's the kind
of prediction that Pinker laughs at but
seventeen years later which is nothing
seventeen years later after this
pinnacle of civilization thirty years of
absolute total war took place that wiped
the high culture of Europe off the map
the high culture of Europe ends in 1914
to 1945 with one of the worst cataclysms
of evil that has ever taken place in the
history of humankind followed by because
of this anti-christian philosophy of
Nazism followed by these decades of mass
murder in the name of this atheist
philosophy of communism that suggests to
me that the Enlightenment narrative is
not quite everything that it cracked up
to be
and so I think this is a serious crisis
I think that personally I think that
Immanuel Kant at the very beginning of
the Enlightenment saw it coming and gave
us a roadmap to to a different way of
thinking about religion a different way
of thinking about both Jewish Judaism
and Christianity which is though is the
way that I think about is is almost in
terms of language and storytelling that
yes we are flesh and blood yes we are a
flesh bag of chemicals but you're also
been and you are the represent you are
the language that speaks to me and to
you a Ben you are a word like your flesh
your body is a word
meaning men and that ban is is real in
the new mineral world or in the mind of
God if you want as as this
flesh-and-blood everything about
everything about the words coming out of
my mouth as physical my brain is
sparking my you know if one's are
pushing it off but the ideas when I'm
expressing you aren't physical at all
and they're either true or they're false
and they're false whether I speak them
or not and all of that is really to me
what the Christian story is it's the
word be made flesh it is that the life
of God becoming seeable realizable which
I think each of us is at some level and
I think I think it's why Jesus spoke in
parables it's not because of necessarily
the meaning of the parables but the
mechanism of the parables once you
accept the mechanism that I can tell you
a story of man's son ran away and then
came back and he welcomed him back I can
tell you that story and you hear moral
meaning in it you know that it has moral
meaning once you do that you accept that
your life is like that too it is a
physical story with a moral meaning and
to me that's all in a way but when Moses
stands before the burning bush and he
sees this eternal thing of destruction
and creation but you know either but
growing bushes and it says I am I am a
an am I am and I you know that that to
me is what this is all about and it's
completely believable
it is completely believable in the realm
of science you don't have to eliminate
science you don't have to make up you
know magic stories about lost bunnies
you don't have to do anything like that
to understand that this world that we're
living in is a world of morality and
meaning and it cannot be that way
without the God we know well how do you
deal with you know the folks like Sam
Harris you spend a lot of time just
clubbing the Bible like a baby seal and
it's in my and when I had Sam in the
room and we were talking about this I he
spent an awful lot of time trying to
pick out you know parts of the Bible
that he didn't like to which my
statement was well the reason you don't
like it is because you've been living in
a in a world that has been shaped by
that document that you really don't like
very much and you know the statement
that I made to him with regard to sort
of the evolution of morality is that
there are certain things that God says
that are predicated on an eternal
unchanging human nature and then there's
certain things that are that God is
saying to people of a time because God
still has to speak a language to a human
being and human beings are incapable of
understanding language that's to be
written a thousand years from now but
still how do you how do you deal with
all the skepticism of religion these
days because you're making a pretty
sophisticated argument about religion I
think the arguments that I think about
religion are similarly sophisticated but
that's not the religion that most people
are taught when they're young right and
and so it seems like that provides easy
mince meat for for cynics who can spend
the rest of the day just as you are I
could going through and cherry-picking
verses that we find troubling on their
face but their arguments not fair
because what Sam Harris does and I like
him too you know I read what he does is
he takes cutting-edge science and
compares it to the most fundamental
literalist religion all the time and he
says that's fair because he says that
science corrects itself but religion is
essentially fundamentalist that's just
not true
it's just not true all human thought
corrects itself and it corrects itself
by comparing itself to reality you know
of reality doesn't you know you Chafee
ology hasn't changed over the last four
thousand years that's that's a
ridiculous thesis so what I think it's
statement to be fair to him is that
theology theoretically shouldn't change
because if it's the eternal Word of God
then why exactly is J your understanding
that it's unfolding to us what he is
essentially saying is if you can turn on
a light bulb but you can't invent a
light bulb then science doesn't exist
that's what he's saying because what
he's saying is if I can pray and
experience God but I can't talk theology
and I'm just a simple guy and I just
believe in this imagery then God doesn't
exist he's making the same argument
there it plenty of people say plenty of
stupid things about science that doesn't
mean science isn't real plenty of people
say simple and simplistic things about
religion that doesn't mean God isn't
real it's ridiculous you know they're
not arguing I want to see Harris argue
with Aquinas I don't want to see Harris
argue with some guy who just knows that
God is there and has given him faith and
meaning and purpose in his life you may
not be able to explain that anywhere
that I can really explain what happens
when I flick on the switch and the light
magically comes on you know so that the
debate is not fair and it begins thicker
has this thing he does where he says
well you know the Holocaust wasn't
because of genetic science and the
nuclear explosions on her Oshima wasn't
because of nuclear science and global
warming's not because of industrial
science but the Crusades is because of
religion
well yeah you can't you can't do all
this stuff is because if you medieval
humans do bad things they do with
science they do with God my argument
against this is the Bible was written by
men we're not Muslims Muslims believe
that the Quran was written with the
finger of God and those words themselves
contain the truth I don't think Jews or
Christians believe that even literalist
Christians I'm not one I mean but even
ones who believe in the absolute we
don't believe this because we can
translate in the Bible the Bible can be
translated the Quran cannot that Muslims
will tell you if you're reading the
Quran not in Arabic you're not reading
the Quran but the Bible can be
translated because it was written by men
to communicate what God had told them
right men make mistakes there's a major
debate so there's to be fair there's men
Orthodox Judaism over this because okay
there's the idea that God did in fact
write the Torah and that was all written
on Mount Sinai by Moses he as dictated
by God at the time and there was major
debate for literally over a thousand
years and Judaism about whether it was
good or not to translate the Bible's
there is predicate for for that Quranic
view at the same time what Judaism has
that I don't believe and I don't wanna
get this wrong but I don't believe
chronic religion does have a lot of is
there was this common-law tradition in
Judaism that also sprang from the same
the same now so even people who are very
fundamentalist about what they believe
about the giving of Bible also believe
that at least in Judaism that there was
an oral torah that was given at the same
exact time which was meant to explain to
human beings what exactly this text
meant jaitley provides the capacity for
us to understand what was happening the
vast world for us yeah right it's really
not the written stuff so so I mean I
think that this is this is important
though I mean my personal belief and
this is not necessarily the you know the
Orthodox belief but my personal belief
is that the Bible was written down by
men it is the story of God explaining
himself to men over time you don't have
to say you can't take any one sentence
out of it and say here is you know it's
not like a fractal where each sentence
ooh shows you the entire world of God
each sentence shows you a history I mean
the the Old Testament is a history a
tremendous cycle of of coming out of
nowhere into Empire and back into into
these versions all the dispersion and
people
that's that happens to every people
sometimes the cycle is cut short
sometimes it goes complete but it shows
you where God is at each part in that
cycle that's an amazing revelation to me
and I think that you can if you can't
find the deep truths that have powered
Western society to both moral
superiority and technological
superiority I think you're missing
something I don't think you're reading
the book right you know I think it's all
there you can see it anybody can take a
book and read it in a certain way and
make it absurd I can do that with
Shakespeare my favorite writer I can
take him and says say oh this is weird
if you read it that way like everything
you have to know how to read it and I
think that that that was also one of
Conn's points where he said we don't we
must not thoroughly need revelation
because we know the truth when we see it
we know we wouldn't recognize revelation
if we didn't have something in us to
greet revelation so you do have to greet
the revelation of the Bible with
something within yourself and I think
that that's you know again I think what
they do with science is they get very
very detailed and elegant in their
arguments about science which I approve
of and then give very blunt and stupid
yeah and not one of them has read any
theology not one of those atheists has
read any serious theology so they're
always arguing with a guy on TV they're
arguing with that televangelist half the
time when you should be I mean Pinker's
spent tons of ink arguing about the
ghost in the machine I don't know
anybody who believes that there's a
ghost in the machine you know that's a
dead end cartesian belief you know that
i think we've we've gotten past and
actually before that we had other more
sophisticated beliefs so they're just
they're just not engaging with real
religion so you're very big on cons and
conte is is sort of a quasi natural law
theorist but not quite
and what's your fondness for for con cuz
you're obviously a deeply religious
Christian tanta is at best a sort of
nominal Christian well what Kant what
Kant was doing was in the moment that he
was what I read him okay and I'm not a
sophisticated philosophy reader but you
know I have read a lot of it and I this
is my take on what he was doing was he
saw very early on in the Enlightenment
in the
this new scientific world as the Germans
did that that God was in trouble and our
beliefs were in trouble but he also saw
what I think is beyond question that
morality could not survive the death of
God and I think me che saw that too a
lot of people saw it you know and so he
came up because it is really difficult
once you start to actually make the
argument that morality doesn't exist you
know it sounds good if you're in your
dorm smoking dope at 3:00 in the morning
but in real life you know you can't
really make the serious argument and he
saw that so he thought well then there
must be a God and in order for there be
a God there really must be sort of two
planes of existing and and I think this
is obviously true the phenomena logical
play and phenomenal plane he called it
and the Newman old plane so and the
phenomenal plane is speaking to us of a
new mental plane that we can never quite
know and this is the remarkable thing
about our cultures I always say our
culture's founded on two people Socrates
and Jesus both of them were dealing with
an intellectual class that didn't
believe in truth both of them believed
that there was a truth neither of them
spoke the truth directly you know Jesus
told stories and he said I am the truth
which is a very sophisticated difficult
you know concept and Socrates was always
asking those annoying questions that got
him killed you know but they never said
they they said there wasn't truth but
they were approaching it they're always
moving toward it and that's essentially
what Kant was doing contact field was
kind of rewriting and updating Plato to
say that yes there is this world outside
the cave where what looking at these
shadows but there is a world of light
that that creates the shadows we can
never quite get to that light but it is
there we do can move toward it and he
did say that the fundament the
fundamentals of Christian belief were
you could believe in the fundamentals of
Christian belief the afterlife judgment
yeah incarnation you could believe in
all those things if you believed in this
numeral world and so all I'm saying is
that he puts down a roadmap of
understanding that I have found very
helpful it's not like I he also has this
wonderful talk about how we receive
receive information it takes shape in
our minds because our minds have a way
of giving it shape but I think it's
turned out to be scientifically the case
you know that to me is really important
because it's one thing to say to me the
world is not as I see as a Hugh
being you know the table is really just
a forcefield or whatever you want to say
but it is true that if I turn north at
53rd Street I'll get the 54th Street
every single time so the world the
phenomenal world that I see it's not I'm
yeah it's not untethered to the new
middle world and I think that that's
important because I think that human
beings are important in and of
themselves and the way we see them is
justified in and of itself so this is a
very that you're making a very natural
law argument to the extent that you say
that the universe is essentially
discoverable Khan's argument is that the
universe you could not necessarily you
could tell teleology from from the
universe around you and sort of the
Aquinas sense but more that by searching
your own moral sensibility you could
come up with the idea of God because we
all have the interior
moral sensibilities so then what need is
there for religion in the first place
why not just be sort of a Content just
just make that your religion because I
really do think and when you read the
Bible a lot of this has to do with
guarantees of the truth the revelation
of the burning bush the the revelation
of the Incarnation these are things
where God is saying to us yes you know
don't I I know I know this path makes
sense I know this relativistic path can
make sense you can analyze things
forever and follow this light follow
this light and I don't think it's it's
one thing to say that we could have
thought of that by ourselves but could
we have believed it by ourselves I'm not
quite sure I'm not I actually don't
believe we could yeah I tend to agree
with that and I think that this is sort
of the Judaic perspective on on Greek
thought for example is there's this this
famous statement by a Yahoo de la vie
was a very famous rabbi and I believe
the 11th century and his statement was
basically that Greek philosophy is
beautiful but has no fruit meaning that
it's it's it's wonderful to study and
it's wonderful to learn about but it
doesn't actually dictate action in the
same way that an implicit command to do
things does or an implicit yeah rulebook
for living does and it's kind of its
kind of arrogant of some of these
thinkers to say well you know we
couldn't even recognize the truth if we
didn't already know the truth what
difference does that make we're walking
around in the dark there's got to be if
there's light at the end of the hallway
you got to be able to see the light to
know which way to work and walk and I
think that that really is
what our faith does in a face says to do
you know but you know when Jesus said
you know love God love your neighbor
everything else is built on that there's
a rabbi right
yeah rabbi Hillel same thing that's or
the reverse he's the silver rule right
he says he says that that which is
hateful to your neighbor do not do yeah
yeah yeah and and I think that when you
have that kind of rule for instance when
I'm reading the Bible and it seems to me
to be telling me that oh this guy I can
get rid of this guy he's no good and go
back to that and I say no if I got there
I made a mistake and I made a mistake
you have to have some basis some light
that you're moving toward and revelation
is that light I don't think I really
don't believe that you can get there any
other way and I think it's tremendously
arrogant to think that you could think
your way to the light because you can
think your way right off the edge of a
cliff and I've seen people do it so how
do we actually Rhian cocaine some of
these beliefs because obviously this is
you know the the work in which you're
engaged is the work in which I'm engage
it's and it's it's daunting obviously
because you have an entire culture that
is built to believe in its arrogance
that it could have created all these
values just tabula rasa even after a
century of us slaughtering each other
unprecedented it's yeah it's it's an
uphill battle I mean get people people
have an easier time believing in no God
than in God yep so how do you get to
this well you know I think the one of
the problems we're having right at this
moment is that politics is the opposite
of thought in some ways that politics
demands that you take it to make a
choice between Democrat and Republican
you know this one or that one and it's
very hard for people to say yeah I'm
choosing the Republican but he's a jerk
he he's just bet you got a better idea
you know this guy is richer hey you know
ideas matter a lot ideas really do
matter a lot because all of us are so
broken and sinful and creepy in some way
you know they're like like this whole
idea that you can point at somebody and
say oh well he did this when he was 17
and therefore you know you think what
does he represent tell me first what he
represents and then tell me whether he
can't represent that or can represent
that and so I think that we are fighting
over ideas or fighting over the stories
we tell I think these two things are
immensely equally important and I think
that what can we do but speak to these
ideas in all their complexity and tell
their so our stories as as clearly as we
can what
can we do and then have faith I do have
faith I do believe that ideas that don't
make sense collapse I believe that that
modernism collapsed because it was
secular and post-modernism which makes
literally no sense whatsoever
you know beep modernism because modern
it exposed something in modernism that
didn't work secular humanism actually
didn't work so I have faith in those
ideas the thing that I think we all
worry about you'd be fool not to worry
about is as you're moving toward the
light as you're moving toward the good
what horrors will occur and we just
don't know you know I mean you live in
faith and you live each day hoping that
this is not that day so you know I would
be remiss if we went through this entire
episode and I didn't ask you you're
talking a lot about narrative about
storytelling
I'd be remiss if I didn't ask you about
your experiences in Hollywood because
obviously you're a Hollywood writer
you've made some money writing movies in
Hollywood you know how do they do just
not talk about any of this around
anybody in Hollywood well eventually
I've virtually got kicked out I mean I
got kicked out one office at a time you
know but I still got kicked out you know
and that was all politics it was just
like during the Bush administration
you'd go in and they say Bush's Hitler
and you say I'm here to sell a story
about ghosts yeah and I I was never able
to say you know yes Bush's Hitler or
even smile a stupid you know grin and
and just accept it I always had to say
well I'm on the other side and I would
get thrown out and once I became loud
enough it really became hard for me to
get work I never minded I kind of was
dragged into the movie business and I
didn't mind getting thrown out and it
would be a horrible life to me not be
able to be able to speak my mind I mean
I'd much rather sit around here talking
to you Jeremy even Knowles and be in
Hollywood you know and and not be able
to say what I thought because I really
wanted to get Justice League for you
know I want to score yeah I mean that's
not that's not my life and I but but it
did bother me because not for myself but
this thesis that half the country does
not deserve to be entertained only
instructed if you are one of them you
deserve to hear jokes at night if you
were one of them you deserve to have
movies and spy films and monster movies
but if you're us they're essentially
every comedian every single one is going
to tell you you're an idiot every movie
is gonna throw your values down the
drain every single film in every TV show
it's going to tell you your country
stinks your religion stinks your values
think your the way you dress is ugly
every single one and then the
electronica why is everybody so angry
like yeah you know you're lucky I think
like you're lucky they just sent Trump
you're lucky they didn't show up
themselves because there's 64 million of
them and they would have been well
within their rights to come this is what
bothers me and it ultimately it all
tomorrow's us me about us because I
don't need them to let me tell a story I
don't need them but they're not so
bright they're not so talented they're
not so deep that we can't do better we
can do better but the problem is is part
of the conservative mindset is to see
how the disaster might happen and so
we're always rushing off to stop the
disaster and you know there are three
things in life that that always come
second place you know children morality
and art you know there's always
something more important than taking
care of your children there's always
something more important than doing the
right thing there's always something
more important than sitting down and
writing a novel that's not gonna make
you as much money is if you wrote you
know like that lousy Trump I hate and
more than or the opposite you know so
those things need care and conservatives
have let them go conservatives have not
cared about the artists they have not
cared about the narrative and they
haven't cared about you know something
that people need to light you know they
need to be delighted they need to hear
they need to see their inner life acted
out so that they can reflect on it and
look it's like looking in the mirror you
know and we've let that go and that was
the thing that bothered me most about
Hollywood was not that they were there
that we weren't you know and and it
really and it still bothers me I mean
it's you know you call up and say here's
an idea about this and I'll go now
because everybody knows who I am and
what I think I will go into rooms now
and say there's 64 million people with
20 bucks in their pocket that you can't
reach and I can let me do it and it's
like no well I want to end up
lefting note and I do have one more
question which is I'm gonna ask you your
favorite movies in your favorite books
in just one second but if you actually
want to hear Drew's answer you have to
be a daily wire subscriber to subscribe
just go to daily wire.com click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation there so through thanks so
much for stopping by and we'll see you
tomorrow man you were just considered in
the Sunday special and go check out
Drew's another Kingdom season 2 it's
only available to subscribers to get
early with our beautiful art from our
art department you really are gonna want
to check it out just another subscriber
benefit when you give us your money go
check it out right now it's been a
pleasure having you this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special event
Shapiro shows Sunday special is produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy Boren associate producer Mathis
Glover edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Dylan case heron makeup is by
Jess wah alvera and title graphics by
Cynthia and gula the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018
[Music]